Chris Pratt went from that funny chubby
guy on Parks and Recreation to bonafide
movie star almost overnight thanks to
his starring roles in blockbusters like
guardians of the galaxy in Jurassic
world but for much of his early career
it seemed as if he was destined to play
on the sidelines his boyfriends and
romantic comedies or coworkers with only
a handful of lines here are some
under-the-radar roles Pratt played
before he became a global superstar
Everwood Pratt's first big break came in
2002 when he was cast as bright Abbott a
jock with a heart of gold on the
critically acclaimed WB series Everwood
Pratt stayed with the show throughout
its four season run most of which dealt
with brights on again off again
relationship with Hanna in real life
though Pratt wound up dating his
on-screen sister revenge's Emily VanCamp
for a number of years they split in 2007
strangers with candy in 2005 Pratt
landed a part in the big screen version
of Amy Sedaris as cult TV comedy
strangers with candy in it he played
brace in another high school jock who
becomes the object of Jerri blanks lusty
whacked-out desires as far as the Chris
Pratt film cannon goes strangers with
candy will likely be remembered best as
that time Chris rocked a hilarious
if unfortunate mullet The OC by the time
the OC headed into its fourth and final
season most people had abandoned the
ones top rated teen soap due to its
recycled plot lines and stale acting
those who stuck around however were
treated to an unexpected creative
revival due in part to Pratt's
performances summers free-spirited
roommate Jay Pratt infused the show with
laughs heart and welcomed weirdness
allowing the OC to end on a higher note
than anyone could have hoped wanted
although Pratt is now known for playing
honky-tonk mean leading men there was a
time in his career when he was relegated
to roles like that coworker you just
want to punch in the face such was the
case in the 2008 Angelina Jolie action
flick wanted in which Pratt angered
co-star James McAvoy's character so much
he eventually got smacked in the face
with a keyboard yeah
was great bro who's the main Bride Wars
another pre fame role Pratt had to try
on for size
playing the bro a suit and tie wearing
fiance has seen in the disastrous 2009
rom-com Bride Wars
fortunately for Pratt fans his role in
the embarrassing flop was overshadowed
by the insane antics of Kate Hudson and
Pratt's on-screen love interest and
Hathaway Moneyball Pratt got his first
legitimate taste of prestige
award-winning movies when Sony cast him
to play real-life first baseman Scott
Hatteberg in the 2011 baseball drama
Moneyball what's your biggest fear a
baseball being hit in my general
direction although the role was small
Pratt held his own opposite his mega
famous co-star Brad Pitt and even
dropped 30 pounds to secure the role
Moneyball marked a stark contrast to
Pratt's goofy affable Andy on Parks and
Recreation setting him up for big movie
roles for years to come zero dark thirty
one year after Moneyball hit theaters
Pratt once again found himself at the
center of an awards Magnum movie this
time in Kathryn Bigelow's zero dark
thirty about the u.s. hunt for Osama bin
Laden Pratt played one of the Navy SEALs
who helped take bin Laden down so uvl
you got you got an Intel source on the
ground okay so how do you know it's bin
Laden her in 2013 Pratt appeared in his
third consecutive Best Picture nominee
her from writer director Spike Jones
this time around he played a co-worker
who goes out on a double date with
Joaquin Phoenix and his virtual bodyless
girlfriend Samantha voiced by Scarlett
Johansson
which is just as weird as it sounds you
mean we're all dumb humans yeah thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]